c'est parti à 17 ans et sa première
sélection en équipe de france pour les
championnats d'europe d'athlétisme
handisport alisme était originaire de
l'indre en chêne pendant trois jours à
blois séance de musculation et travail
sur piste avec deux autres athlètes à la
championne paralympique mariés amélie le
fur et valentin bertrand un stage
encadré par le coach du pôle espoirs de
saint cyr sur loire
il faut savoir qu'à nice entraîne entre
quatre et cinq fois par semaine sur sur
le pôle depuis moins de septembre qu'
elle a une progression qui est justifiée
parce que avait quand même des qualités
physiques mais qui occupa la de pouvoir
faire ses performances et maintenant je
prépare pour pour repenser championnat
pour qu'il se passe le mieux possible
ouais c'est bien mieux voilà c'est
difficile j'ai pas mal galéré j'avoue
que c'est dur mais voilà on a là
l'équipe qui ce qui soutient pas mal
donc on peut on peut s'entraider en plus
une petite gêne est que je suis avec
avec en ce moment marie amélie et
valentin bertrand qui connaissent déjà
ils me mettent beaucoup il me parle
soutiennent que c'est dur mais on
s'entraide et c'est sympa alice
participera au 100 et 200 m à berlin fin
août
marie-amélie au saut en longueur une
championne paralympique qui partage son
expérience avec la jeune athlète
je lui fais confiance sur le fait
qu'elle ne se satisfera pas d'une
sélection c'est en fait c'est ce qui est
important sur un profil jeune comme ça
c'est de se dire mais ma sélection j'ai
eu ma saison allait terminer non ta
saison elle se terminera quand tu feras
tu as finale et que tu auras vraiment
atteint cet objectif là je suis très
contente parce que c'était mon objectif
de la saison mais c'est pas mon objectif
final moi je vise plus haut donc de plus
je vais pas m'arrêter là
enfin je vis quoi bein je disparais 2024
si possible